[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday July 31st 2017 what's going on
how are you what's going on oh Jesus
Christ
how's your summer is it going to be a
heat wave the heats coming back oh my
god
please try to stay inside inside the air
conditioning if you don't have air
conditioning please try to remember to
keep your windows open and stick your
head through the opening in the window
not in the solid part of the wall you
know they do that [ __ ] on the news they
try to help old people not die in the
summer season what a [ __ ] way to go
you live almost a century and just you
know you've lived through the wars
you've lived through the depression
you've lived throughout the [ __ ] New
York and the 70s and all that what
finally gets you a hot summer day and
you just sitting there so slowly Lord
you just can't you just can't get to the
window it's like when you'd watch
wrestling right and it's one of those
tag-team wrestling matches and the guy
just can't get to his teammate the
[ __ ] slap his hand and tagamet
that's what it is I think that's it they
light up they'd find them face down in
wrestling trunks the greatest generation
stormed the beaches of Normandy taken
out by a [ __ ] heat wave does it every
year how many heroes how many years
people are we going to put up with the
Sun taking another one of our heroes
away I swear to god you know maybe if
there was a different administration
they would handle the threat of the Sun
right am i talking politics now is that
what I'm doing
let's talk politics why why do we keep
[ __ ] with this douche in Korea why
don't you just leave them alone you know
what I mean it's like when you're on the
subway the crazy guy comes in the car
you don't look at him you don't start
talking to him
just [ __ ] leave them alone
leave them alone is nothing - why don't
they just let the [ __ ] guy you know
run his country the way he wants to run
his [ __ ] country send some food and
then feed the [ __ ] people why does he
have to have the same [ __ ] ideas
about strip malls that we do in order us
for us to get along with them huh
haven't we proven that it doesn't matter
what kind of government you have in the
end there's going to be human beings
running it so they're going to selfishly
[ __ ] the whole thing up anyways who
gives a [ __ ] if he's over there lighting
off his [ __ ] m-80s let him do it the
guy is clearly unbelievably insecure he
clearly is is trying to somehow follow
in the footsteps of his dad's giant
[ __ ] shoe solo he's probably smaller
I don't know how tall those guys are
over there but whatever tall four over
there big shoes for North Korea
especially with all the lack of
nutrition that's got to stunt the growth
of your feet he's there right why don't
they just [ __ ] it you know we should
like when you shoot something off we
should just feed his ego oh there you go
where to go there Kim Jong Il's a second
whatever your [ __ ] name is
hey yo fatty case I was a good one
dude that's it you like that look at
look at ours it's awesome fist bump
good man good man hey you say there's a
copy of that last year's Super Bowl
check it out man it's [ __ ] amazing
what do you got you got a mug Gangnam
style DVD you want to trade with us why
can't we just try to get along with this
guy what is the [ __ ] problem huh like
we give a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] he's doing
to his people these [ __ ] who run [ __ ]
over here they don't know [ __ ] how many
people upside down in their own house
they didn't give a [ __ ] about the people
in New Orleans they give a [ __ ] about
those people in North Korea no they do
not
no they do not you know what it is that
if sitting on a bunch of material that
you could turn into those ducted those
beats by dre and goddamnit we want it so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to act like this [ __ ] god damn
fatso with his [ __ ] three missiles
it's going to
a problem yeah I don't to just leave the
guy loan they're talking now right
according to Google News that I didn't
even read it all I did was just click on
it since US allies prepared to use
overwhelming force in North Korea
general says we're prepared to shoot a
bunch of missiles in his general area
says the general hoping that one of them
lands on him and we kill as few innocent
people as possible they would never say
that
the US Senate's allies are prepared to
use rapid and lethal rapidly thil and
overwhelming force if necessary
against North Korea the commander of the
US Pacific Air Force's warned Saturday
night and why are we doing this because
this guy's shooting off his own
fireworks because he's testing missiles
the way we do North Korea remains the
most urgent threat to regional stability
O'Shaughnessy said o shaughnessy you've
done it again
Jesus Christ we really gotta go in there
and blow this guy up with a bunch of
other people just trying to [ __ ] get
to work there's got to be another way to
do it don't don't know we have any James
Bond's guys they can just kind of go in
there and start banging the hottest
ships chicks in North Korea is they
subtly try to kill him you know
but the power of his dick is so
overwhelming they forget to kill him and
then he realized and by the time they
realized I was supposed to kill that guy
but I was so busy having orgasms right
he's already out the door he's got the
passcodes and then he goes down there
how would you kill that guy how would
you kill that fat bastard you know you
know what I would do I give him a honey
of a hand
you know the glazed ones that they have
around Christmas except in the glaze
would be some sort of cyanide that's
where you hide the poison you know and
he would just be staring at me which is
mouth would be watering so much that he
couldn't wait for the official taste
tester to give it a try you know and he
would literally die while making himself
a sandwich you know when you're so
hungry you're making the sandwich and
you're a [ __ ] thrown chunks of meat
in your mouth that's what he would be
doing so the two pies
look he looks like a white bread guy
doesn't he he's definitely not a
multigrain you know do you think he gets
in everything bagel on the way to work
every day and here was bastard I bet he
doesn't even have to wear deodorant you
know there's a lot of things to like
about him he's fat you know so he's
non-threatening you know that means he
likes to [ __ ] stay up late Netflix
and chill you can see that about him you
know
you think he knows how to dance have you
noticed that about little people and in
fact and fat people they transcend race
when it comes to dancing you know it's
like white guys can't dance pretty much
general unless they're fat or they're a
little person then all of a sudden
they're just [ __ ] it's just like wow
were you in the beaded video what's
going on here is because they had to
that's what happens you have to there's
a certain amount of ice cream that you
eat where the laws of nature just take
over and at some point you have to learn
how to dance or you're just going to be
heading into an abyss of sadness that
you know there's not enough Chips Ahoy
in the world can fill that void or is it
that they get that sweating to the
oldies Richard Simmons thing and that
just kind of launches this talent they
didn't know this is just for fat people
I don't know about little people you
know I think little people because
they're down at the ground they can see
the steps easier you know with like
Michael Jackson first moonwalked you
know everybody was as tall as Michael
Jackson so we couldn't figure out what
he was doing with his feet but little
people were down at the ground I got
that [ __ ] right and the next day you're
in the subway don't don't don't don't
don't
Oh boom boom it was like [ __ ] eight
little people all coming at you okay and
you knew did you ever see that you ever
go into the subways of Brooklyn and
there was a bunch of little people doing
recreating the bad video eject all
faculties go cousin
bad I'm bad know what's going on I'm in
a stupid mood I'm trying to how would
you solve North Korea you know it's fine
he's like a bit he's like baby fat
that's what I like about that guy look
if you are shorts it probably look like
though old cutie pies there you get
ready for a nap all you did you did you
want to go to Brooklyn today and watch
us eat real people food while you keep
drinking milk alright and no I don't
know I don't know what I was talking I
was talking about some [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] yeah so why it why like honestly
what would happen if we just left that
guy alone you know what would happen if
you just I'm seriously asking this if
you lifted all the sanctions and he was
able to trade with the world and they
were able to [ __ ] get some food in
there whatever the [ __ ] going on if
you just honestly just let him do his
[ __ ] I mean we shoot our [ __ ]
missiles all the time we don't usually
and we do this is what kills me how do
we even know what the [ __ ] he's doing
over there who has [ __ ] time to be
watching this [ __ ]
can you imagine if that was your goddamn
job and then you going home on the
subway and then you sit next to me and
you watching me losing my [ __ ] because I
can't download the new operating system
and you're sitting there dealing with
the fact that there's some chubby little
fella on the other side of the world
shooting up some [ __ ] that could
possibly be on its way over here right
now I don't know do you think if the
animals had the abilities had the
ability to shoot those missiles do you
think they would do it in an effort to
try to wipe all of us out so they could
just go back to [ __ ] catching trout
in a stream you know if there was going
to be an animal out there that would
betray us which would species do you
think it would be you know it has to be
something at least at the level of a
bear reptiles are out reptiles would
like you know they're they're like yeah
there's those kids that go to the
reptiles have like learning disabilities
right they have like [ __ ] dyslexia
abd you know they like the ritalin kids
of the animal kingdom are they even
considered an animal there's a reptile
and animal I was to get this [ __ ] an
amphibian right an amphibian is
something that can be it's like Aquaman
right he's onto the ocean he's talking
to a dolphin and then later on that
night you know he's getting sushi I'd be
[ __ ] up right it's not a date getting
sushi there's dates sitting there
looking at like you know you just seem
like you're somewhere else you just got
like the way of the world and you
sitting there going like I wonder if I'm
eating somebody that helped me out one
time remember that [ __ ] and for some
reason they would all come and help them
they never really explained that did
they why they all liked them why they
would interrupt whatever the [ __ ] it is
that they were doing to stop some other
[ __ ] people in a boat
bringing a key at cocaine or some [ __ ]
into the US and it's just like like a
whale doesn't even know what cocaine is
why is it going to what hurt its tail
smashing this boat there's as much as it
can smash the boat
this is pointy stuff right is the mast
and all of that he could hurt himself
and all he gets into thank you
you know this Aquaman go hey thanks a
lot by the way there's a bunch of
plankton over there little heads up no
one's seen it yet ah Thank You Aquaman
he never did you just be like oh thank
you
how [ __ ] insecure these goddamn fish
here's another thing too I'm sick of
[ __ ] hot newscasters male and female
alright what do you what are you trying
to do here you know I don't need to be
aroused when I'm [ __ ] listening to
world news holy [ __ ] what happened to
that [ __ ] lady's face oh it won't go
down come on go down scroll down and I I
don't I don't get how to use computers
there's something on the side where is
it where is the lady I an Arizona woman
played dead wait a second oh this is all
this clickbait stuff Kendall Jenner's
nude photos sparks who gives a [ __ ] she
really is the best-looking one of all of
them isn't she
no offense to Caitlyn alright so I guess
now we're going so we're going to we're
having a war with Afghanistan we're
having one with Iraq and now we're going
to have one with North Korea you know
isn't this like when hope the Home Depot
opens so many [ __ ] locations they
like started putting each other out of
business
all right Jesus Christ we're going to do
another one we're going to start another
one all right what are you going to do
Inc you know the [ __ ] of this I mean
what do I know I'm just another [ __ ]
with the podcast she's trying to
struggle through an hour you don't I
really wish I just wished like you know
why can't they just do it did some guy
shooting off his firecrackers you don't
like it just go [ __ ] do it stop
dragging me into it showing me what this
guy can do and how his missiles can
[ __ ] you know his little roman candle
can [ __ ] somehow land on my house
what does that do for me
Michel dress up putting some plywood up
on top of my house I got hurricanes
coming Christ you're in the [ __ ] Navy
you go that's your job
does it world news when I can't put
together my new hour stand up oh shut up
go [ __ ] yourself what he wants for me um
so Oh anyway so my daughter was uh
grabbing onto this pleather couch that
we have here alright because she's
learned she's learning to crawl and as
funny she was like planking today you
know doing like not like what the kids
did on the Internet we just laid face
down face planting is what I thought it
should be called she was like literally
doing she was in upper push-up position
how about that the upper push-up
position and she was learning something
and you know and I should just let her
figure [ __ ] out instead I went there you
go there you go and then she just
dropped down to the floor looked up the
mean smile was like I just distracted so
anyways they got this pleather couch
here and her fingernails are really long
and and she was making that finger
nailed down the chalkboard sound and it
was driving me nuts so against my gut I
decided to cut her fingernails which I
do Nia has told me to do I said I don't
want to do it things are too small she
Wiggles them around and it's I don't
want to do it so
I got the first floor done correctly
then I did her thumb and she made this
face and started crying and I looked as
she was wiggling her finger and I
thought I was underneath it and I I just
I just gave her the little little little
cut on a vial God and now the family's
here I got to go get some pizza I'll
talk to em I really going to pause in
this right now so I made like a little
cut on a finger and it was I probably
the worst feeling I've had as an adult
and you know and she was fine two
seconds later but for the rest of the
night every time she cried I was
convinced it was because of that little
[ __ ] scratch I put on a finger
worst [ __ ] Filan ever and I don't
know why I had to pass it on to you but
you know what if they could sit there
and tell me but this little [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] over there is shooting off as I
guess that's what you do I'm going to
let you know what's going everything
awful that's going on in the world and
I'll let you know what's going on in my
world that was awful and I got to get
off the hang on a second hang on a
second let me see what's going on as far
as people who are coming over Jesus - I
got too much family here - keep going
I'll try to go for another few minutes
here so yeah so that happened and I just
immediately stopped so now she has like
short fingernails at one hand and long
ones on the other and I'm trying to get
my wife to clip the other ones she
hasn't had the time and it's driving me
nuts aesthetically you know what I mean
it's like the fact that like the fact
that five of our fingers I have short
nails in the other five don't is driving
me [ __ ] crazy I don't know why it's
the same thing you know when black guys
walk around that pants hanging off their
ass like that's that you just want to
pull them up you know and then the white
guy version of that is those white guys
that walk around with their shoes untied
it's [ __ ] I don't know why it has no
effect on my life I don't know what it
is it drives me up the wall pull up your
pants are you [ __ ] sneakers okay just
can you be an adult
[Music]
you ever seen those guys to take it to
the point literally they have a long
shirt on that goes past their ass and
then they have a belt it's like I don't
know they can still walk I saw a guy one
time his pants would literally below his
junk I don't know it's crazy kids you
know I guess they guess they have to
keep taking it further than the
generation before I figure at some point
that someone's got to be a rebel and go
the other way and you start yanking them
up you know till you do the old man
thing woods right underneath your man
boobs anyways you know what it became
fascinated with since I got here because
New York has changed so much with all
these glass towers I get tallest
building in Manhattan this is new they
used to be this place called the Drake
Hotel with Zeppelin and all these guys
stayed and this place that replaced it
is 432 Park Avenue and you have to see
the [ __ ] views of this place it's so
it's so tall like you can see the
roundness of the world or the flatness
you know depending on what you believe
you can see the end of like you know
those people that I think they're they
think we kind of live in like a giant
coffee cup is that what it is you know I
mean there has to be like even people
who [ __ ] don't think it's round it's
got to be half round right like you cut
a tennis ball in half and you just
filled it all in with land and ocean
right do they think it's like that I
don't know dude this building on the top
floor they have this website I think on
a clear day you can almost see the
Tappan Zee Bridge you actually look over
the Freedom Tower past the Statue of
Liberty past Staten Island out to the
ocean and the top floor
I can't member I already talked about
some forecast went for 95 million
dollars I think you get the top two
floors or something like that and then
the floor below it the apartment below
it the second highest one is still for
sale at 85 million bucks and I think and
the reason why that isn't selling is who
the [ __ ] is going to pay 85 million
dollars to still have some [ __ ]
walking on as its salient can get
[ __ ] keep it down up there you know
[Music]
some rich guy walking around I think you
know they probably did that I would
think at that point you could literally
be wearing tap shoes and like it's so
expensive the person below you can hear
it they got have some sort of
soundproofing or spongy floors I don't
know what it is because I know people
with that goddamn bridge would not
tolerate listen to somebody walk you
probably have our herd of horses up to
the person below it wouldn't have it so
probably the reason it's not selling is
they just can't handle it
they can't handle if you have that kind
of money you want to be the swing and
dick in your building there's somebody
else above you drop it as jumped on your
forehead every time you walk out the
wind out the door
can't have that what I did find
interesting was that the the building
was so tall that he actually had to call
the FAA because I learned last time I
was out here I flew up to a gig and a
helicopter right I just want to see fly
with the George Washington Bridge just
to do it and he said bravo airspace
which would be LaGuardia JFK and Newark
was 900 feet and above and this
buildings like 1,300 and change so it
actually literally goes up into
commercial airspace so at nighttime
there's like these floors that are
always lit which is pretty cool and I
don't know if that's because of the the
FAA or what they usually just have like
blinking red lights on the top or
something like that like hey don't hit
this me and anyways I don't know who has
who has that kind of money
who is that kind of money
how long is that elevator ride and also
how long before somebody based jumps off
the top of that thing and if you did
could you make it out to Ellis Island
actually you know something as far as
like jumping that's not that high up if
you're going to try to fly right when
those guys don't they usually jump off a
mountain Ron Burgundy I want to shout it
from I don't they don't think that you
jump off a mountain they go all the way
down a mountain right Jesus bill you've
really talked yourself into a corner
here haven't you yeah I have I have you
know what I was going to do last week I
was going to sing the praises of a water
taxi which I think I did a water taxi
about how great it was underrated taking
the water taxi in New York from from
Manhattan to Brooklyn or vice versa
there man adding out to do Jersey
whatever you want to do it's awesome
right and no sooner and I took the local
to we made like 10 stops and it took an
extra half an hour but it was just
relaxing it was beautiful I made the
mistake of saying how great it was in
like three days after I said that one of
those yellow ones the guy didn't slow
down in time he smashed into the dock
and like 30 people got hurt which means
really probably 12 got hurt the other 18
are looking for a payday this guy just
came cruising in he was probably texting
I just don't understand how you screw up
that bad with a boat there was bit a
little bit weather was fine it was a
clear day like what did you do he just
came cruising in that was probably the
guys last run of the day that chickies
been texted he wanted to bang her she
finally texted him back hey Lee he doing
I'm at a bar on Pier whatever a day and
he was like oh look it's going down oh
[ __ ]
BAM Rick but he goes flying you know in
the boat I was on
the guy driving it he's like surrounded
by glass so it's not like you know
airline pilots you know when they have a
hard landing they just won't open the
door they just stay there you know you
can't seem because then you go into the
jet way when you're on a boat there's
nowhere to hide you know people just
walk by you just been sorry about that
Jesus sorry about that everybody laying
on the ground I know I'm not supposed to
laugh at stuff like that but the end of
the day I wasn't on the boat and no one
I know got hurt so there is something
kind of larry's about it unless somebody
got seriously injured you know is this
going to spark an internet controversy
now is they going to prove be a group of
six people that complain all of the
exact same time and it gets picked up
you know we're going to go to war with
North Korea but first podcasting can it
go too far
xx so I'm trying to get up to thirty
minutes here because I don't have any
advertising right now and I don't have
any other questions either the New York
Yankees are crushing it ladies and
gentlemen they're a they were down five
games to the two hundred million dollar
Boston Red Sox my two hundred million
dollar Boston Red Sox your two hundred
million dollar Red Sox okay because when
teams start spending that kind of money
like it's got to come from somewhere it
can't just come from Red Sox fans it
even comes from people who are not Red
Sox fans so anyways they I don't know we
lost so many [ __ ] games in a row we
finally won last night Saturday night
I'm recording this Sunday and one nine
to eight actually scored a bunch of runs
for once but the Yankees they just
surgeon but they're only up by half a
game and there's like I don't know 900
games left we'll see what happens
but I'm watching the Yankees all week on
the YES Network here one of my favorite
things to do watch them and root against
them it's what I always did when I get
the baseball package I lived in New York
for so long it's hard for me to turn on
the Red Sox because I was so long my
baseball watching was watching the YES
Network rooting against the Yankees
[Music]
it's bizarre and somewhere in there
Sweet Caroline came out and I don't know
this is just a bunch of weird [ __ ] that
happens it's Fenway now I went away for
too long and I came back and I just
don't recognize it but I am back into it
and I really wish our team would just
focus on trying to win and stopped
getting into arguments with Dennis
Eckersley all right he's a hall-of-famer
he's I love what he does he's great at
his job and I don't mind that he
criticizes the friggin players and Jesus
Christ it's like all these stories that
they you know people if they kick the
[ __ ] out of here yelling in them on like
the team plane and everything like well
why would you do that to a hall-of-famer
you know what I mean if people it's a
Hall of Fame stand-up comedian criticize
my act I would listen to him be like all
right legit evidently I need to work on
some stuff you know what I mean I
certainly wouldn't start screaming at
them on the team
comedian plane which is basically a
commercial airliner all right
I'm going to take a break down because I
got to go out with the family and I'll
come back I read some advertising and
some questions and we will wrap it up I
have not watched the f1 race yet because
I don't have the channel and like I
mentioned earlier you know I don't know
a lot of people that are into it none of
my friends are so no one's really going
to ruin it for me but if I had to guess
I would hope Lewis Hamilton didn't win
again I hope he's just not going to run
away from this thing and it just becomes
Mercedes Mercedes Mercedes like it did
last year I hope that'll won you know
just to keep it keep it exciting before
they go on the break or whatever all
right that's it I'm done babbling I will
love well you guys will be like two
seconds I'll be back in two seconds sir
hey and I'm back I hope this isn't too
love I [ __ ] the battery ran on my
other thing this is me continuing on
with the Monday morning podcast Oh
lovely Mia how are you this morning I
know you're not in a good mood
she's not in a good mood you know every
couple when you travel there's the one
person that's freaking out that we're
going to miss the plane and then there's
the other person who could like give a
[ __ ] he is the one that freaks out like
oh my god did we leave enough time did
we bring extra batteries in case there's
no flashlights on the plane I don't even
feel I don't even know what airline were
about Delta Delta R William Delta I
don't I never [ __ ] them you know what
I on the way to the airport when the
driver goes you know I always know what
airport in phones for the most part the
dude just goes what airline and that's
when I check my itinerary might INRI I
am going on virgin I am going on you
knighted ooh mommy baby all right so
since I last talked to you which was
yesterday
the Yankees duh Yankees lose but so did
the Red Sox we're still a half a game
out by the way New York sports press
enough with the judge [ __ ] Jesus Christ
all rise then they had this thing you
know because you got the gap between his
teeth they're like the to the whole
tooth and nothing but that it his last
name is judge jesus [ __ ] christ
why does wine do sports pages get away
with puns you know every [ __ ] other
day they got some stupid pun on the back
of the sports page because they can't
write a [ __ ] joke and they shouldn't
be able to cuz just sports writers
should just tell me who won the game
okay I don't need you to say Oh
Jeter Oh golly Jeter like why is it
always have to be a pun sitting in there
you're all a bunch of writers you can't
come up anything better than that the
tooth the whole tooth and nothing but
the tooth well it's just like [ __ ] he
just ruined my goddamn day I hate when I
record yourself my [ __ ] computer this
[ __ ] goddamn air conditioning will
not shut off just shut off already
so [ __ ] loud off office yeah ah why
is it still on mode low high
Oh low there's no [ __ ] option here
than off that did it sorry [ __ ] this
[ __ ] goddamn American either doesn't
work or it's drowning out conversation
you know what I mean it's like somebody
you just hoping is going to pass out but
that last 10 minutes before they do they
just interrupt on everybody so this
[ __ ] air conditioning thing um anyway
so let's get to some of the advertising
here for this week with this book is wow
that's not it God dang it come on come
on we can do it oh look who's here
Oh would you look at this it's old zip
recruiter are you hiring well are you um
do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidate that says we'll
settle for this person not the person
who you know well at least he put
deodorant under one armpit we want the
best one the smartest best-looking most
[ __ ] candidate right who's kidding
who that's what you want you want people
who know their job how to do it
correctly and who look good that's what
you want you know regardless of what
these feminists might say regardless of
what these fatties want to talk about at
the end of the day you want a
good-looking [ __ ] reliable employee
and that's where zip recruiter comes in
how is if recruit a different well I'm
glad you didn't ask
I'm glad to copy ass for you with zip
Irina you can post your job to 100 plus
job sites with just one click then
they're powerful technology for their
basic horseshit on the internet or we'll
call it powerful technology efficiently
matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else and that's why
is it
I shut my [ __ ] tooth my wedding ring
it's different
unlike other job sites different cooter
doesn't depend on candidates binding you
goes up grab bud bulls and find them in
fact over 80% of jobs posted on zip
recruiter gets a qualified candidate in
just 24 hours
no Justin emails are calls to your
office simply screen rate and manage
candidates all in one place would fit
easy-to-use dashboard find out today why
zip recruit has been used by businesses
of all sizes to find the most qualified
job candidates with immediate results
there it is
and right now my listeners can post jobs
on tipeee recruiter for free that's
right
clean just go to zip recruited comm / /
that zip recruited us comm / / one more
time hi Vick accomplish forever all
right
Oh movement watches MV MT watches
pronounced movement was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank the watchmakers goal is to change
the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices
movement watches start at just 9 to 5
dollars at a department store you're
looking at four to five hundred bucks
movement figured out that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail mock up providing
the best possible price classic design
quality construction style minimalism
over 1 million watches sold in 160
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement comm / burn this watch has has
a really clean design seriously I've
been getting compliments ever since I
put it on no no now is the time to step
up your watch can go to movement comm /
4 join the movement and lastly but not
leastly the original advertisers of this
podcast
it's stamps.com
stamp save you time and money which can
you you can use to grow your business I
said I can mail any letter any package
just using my computer printer into the
mailman comes and picks it up I was
reading so well now I'm going to [ __ ] up
this lesson avoid the hassle man of the
post office and mail everything from
postcards to envelopes to packages
domestic or international create your
stamps account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease no long term
commitments click print mail and you're
done no need to lease an expensive
postage made up I use stamps con
whenever I'm sending out my posters if I
want to warm myself out after a show if
I can figure out how to use it so can
you because I'm not smart and right now
you too can enjoy stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial before we trial with the
jury of your peers plus postage and a
digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps calm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage type infer that stamps calm
enter Burke stamps calm never go to the
post office again hey how about it for
OJ Simpson huh he's out again what's he
gonna do he's out again he's going to
kill not one but two he's out again
it's OJ Run For Your Lives I love what
he said you know I lived a pretty
confrontation confrontation free life
and then still other than when he killed
those two people I mean he was a hell of
a guy
I don't here we go let's um let's read
some of the questions here for this week
microchipping says revelation 13 17 is
called mock of the beast now sorry for
this click here this is going to be loud
block your ears three two one click what
the [ __ ] is that I know I left it up
there we go revelation this is the exact
reason why I don't read the Bible
library revelation 3:17 let's see if I
can get this here the temple of God was
opened in heaven and there was seen in
his temple the Ark of his Testament the
Ark of God's Testament is the Holy of
Holies the second apartment of the
sanctuary I already lost me okay every
time when you can rent a room out this
church in the or he has won a lieutenant
in the ministration of the early
Tabernacle which served unto the example
and shadow of heaven of heavenly things
this apartment was opened only by the
great day of atonement for the cleansing
of the sanctuary
therefore the announcement that the
temple of God was opened okay well there
you go so I guess that explains
microchipping thank you Bible there
really is a good book I mean I would
wrap I I think I understand my
computer's more than I get the Bible I
just why can't they just write it in
[ __ ] today's English they do that
with every other book of lies I'm
kidding all right I work for the
microchip company in Wisconsin okay some
stick [ __ ] offered my boss a TV show
what the [ __ ] are they going to call it
how to shed your employees rights thanks
[ __ ]
sorry just venting love your stuff thank
God for your gifts you don't punch a
clock for Satan or me video you just
work for a company in Wisconsin quit the
[ __ ] job then what I want to do I
don't know collect unemployment and not
be microchipped come on people don't
give Delta Airlines your fingerprints
all right please don't do this people
please don't give in to this don't go to
Tiger Stadium and give them your
fingerprint scene off the stand in line
for a [ __ ] pretzel you [ __ ] dope
and please don't be dumb enough to think
we'll do my credits [ __ ] good luck if
somebody steals my identity dummy
they're going to create a false credit
report all they need is the lis hard
Oswald depended on which will be you and
your fingerprints you [ __ ] dope yeah
you know in the future there's going to
be a knock on the door and they're going
to question why you killed a hooker and
you the Ukraine and you'll be like I've
never been there in my life oh yeah you
think of prints were that a set up is
the story of a person who didn't kill a
hooker
now he's getting banged in the ass in
Ukraine because he left his fingerprints
at the ballpark
because he wanted a course life alright
ah um sorry
alright vacuums gathering information
paint big bald Billy thought you might
enjoy this article in regards to your
recent podcast on companies and
fingerprints now it seems like those
robotic vacuums are selling maps of the
inside of your house so you can get
furniture ads yay
massive Aussie fan can't wait to
hopefully see see you when I go over to
the u.s. in the spring of 2018 yeah
things are just changing so friggin
rapidly you know what I was really going
to be interesting is when they microchip
everybody okay they microchip everybody
and then they put all the cash there's
no longer any cash what's going to be
interesting then is all these [ __ ]
you know drug dealers all these [ __ ]
I don't know anybody who just didn't
trust banks and put a sack of money in
the [ __ ] wall what do you do with
that not you know now it's all onions
now that's not even worth anything you
got to show up with all this [ __ ] they'd
be like hey man where did you get this
money
you're gonna be like hey man I earned
this money and I already paid taxes on
it man they're gonna be like hey man you
got to prove that and like came in I
can't and I'm gonna be like hey man well
they [ __ ] your bag cash what's going on
Nino did you like my song the bucket
microchips
doot-doot doot-doot is the story oh
you're just walking on you get ready
yeah you get so nervous on days where we
fly Jesus okay well that was fun yeah so
anyways these [ __ ] lazy ass fat [ __ ]
by these computers that just these
little robots that back and sweep up
after them you know they're eatin like
Ritz crackers with like ice cream in the
middle of it whatever fat people do
right they're always creating some new
food some unholy matrimony of Cobo
hydrates and [ __ ] sugars they're too
[ __ ] lazy to get off their ass and
use a vacuum cleaner so they have this
robot do it and then they map the inside
of this person's house you know so they
can do what with it I don't [ __ ] them
so they can sell them an l-shaped couch
cuz Thai people sit on el-sheikh couches
can they swing their leg up to that you
know that other side of it I don't know
why I'm making fun of the fatties today
because they started with that [ __ ]
guy over there and uh whatever his
[ __ ] name I don't even know the guys
name because it you know cuz he's crazy
I don't need to know about this guy we
should get him to come over to the
[ __ ] Detroit Tigers ballpark and his
finger prints then we'll put it on
something we'll go over there were
arrests and we'll stick him in a JS old
cell how mad would he be
he's magic that guy ever went to jail
just standing here you know all that
hair on top of his head but nowhere else
on his body you know he's one of those
weird hairless adults right alright
girlfriend broke up with me because I
like your podcast thanks me thanks for
helping me weed out the chunks mate come
back to sk sometime sasuke chauhan hope
you enjoyed it their girlfriend broke up
with me because I like your [ __ ] I would
like to heard more details on that one
what was it that she didn't like about
the podcast my annoying voice my
tone-deaf singing my inability to read
out loud
alright addiction to on like
prostitution tuition tuition dear Trojan
bill over the course of the last year
have become addicted to online
prostitution Jesus Jesus Christ through
the courage you have you just go online
and you just have her come over to your
[ __ ] place like you're ordering a
goddamn pizza what is it like when you
look through that [ __ ] hole and you
see her walking down the [ __ ] hallway
the hole in your door whatever you call
that thing the little cycling she comes
stumbling out of the elevator it started
off as curiosity and what would be like
to [ __ ] a stranger for money in snow
balled into me spending a percentage of
almost every paycheck on hookers
anywhere from 60 to 300 try to stick
with the 300 dollar hooker you really
get what you pay for
buh-buh-buh is the story of a bunch of
venereal diseases he said I broke up
with my girlfriend a few months ago she
had no idea but I didn't want to drag
her into this well dude you can't
[ __ ] do this when you're in a
relationship with somebody he said I
recently got tested I came up clean
thank God is what I was going to say and
he wrote it too thank God no one knows
what I did I do this and I prefer to
keep it that way but I can't help myself
from going onto those websites and
meeting with these up of these women I
feel like it's getting worse every month
it's already cost me my relationship
it's costing me a fortune and I'm too
embarrassed to ask anyone I know for
help what should I do and I'm sorry if
Nia is in the room I'm completely
disgusted by this I'm pretty disgusted
with myself too
alright this is what you have to do the
second you wake up you got to rub one
out all right and then you go to work
and at lunch you go that was delicious
excuse me and you excused
yourself you go in and you rub one out
at them in the bathroom right now unless
you can unless you can't lock the door
and then when you come home rub one out
again okay and then that's it
and then you take your [ __ ] phone and
you throw it in the freezer if you have
a landline you rip it out of the wall
I actually if I was you if this is like
if you spending this amount of money I
would just uh I would go to a therapist
you know and just say yeah I'm addicted
to online prostitution I mean therapist
to here everything okay that's actually
like that's like easy listening music to
them compared to some of the [ __ ] they
got you know people come in there talk
about how they got molested by one of
their parents I mean it's crazy [ __ ]
you're just like hey you know I like
banging hookers today it's costing me a
lot of money and I'd like to stop and
they'd be like oh my god you're sort of
functional by all means lay down on my
couch and let's [ __ ] talk about this
why do you feel you want to get
prostitutes
why wouldn't you want to be with a real
girl a regular woman um alright i
snooped through my husband's phone it's
another song
i snooped through my husband phone and I
liked it this one concerning good
morning Billy
good morning Billy on sunday morning my
husband had his work phone alarm set to
5:30 a.m. of course the only person it
wakes up is me after I turned the alarm
off I decided to go through his phone
you [ __ ] course can we go through
your [ __ ] it's selfish [ __ ] horse I
have to admit that it wasn't my proudest
moment all right that I forgive you
you're a nice person just jump run but I
am insecure while looking at his message
I see that there are texts from a phone
number without contact information and
quickly figure out it is his
ex-girlfriend's number in the text
message there's a lot of flirting as
well as my husband complaining about my
appearance oh Jesus Christ well this is
what you get for snooping and eventually
asking
fer to get drinks together while we were
visiting his family for Father's Day in
their hometown oh Jesus
they were together for six years on and
off through college in high school she
cheated on him more than once then when
we got together she harassed me on
Facebook and took an 8 hour bus ride to
try and meet me oh yes oh this [ __ ] is
crazy and she's great in bed that's
what's going on
I had to ignore all my initial reactions
toward her and just ended up ignoring
her I didn't want her in my life
I confronted him about it and his only
response was why would I go into his
phone and then if I go looking for
something I'm going to find it Jesus
Bryson when I asked him why he did it
he just said he didn't know he has
ignored me ever since I'm not sure where
to go from here thank you you are
amazing at colossal cluster fest too bad
you didn't get to finish your set
hopefully you're in the Bay Area get
soon all right you know something
I apologized to Konya for 15 [ __ ]
times in all of whom enjoyed [ __ ] um
well he's not leaving any doors open
here I guess what I would do is Nia I'm
just too busy packing I don't know what
do you do here you're married you
obviously have kids unless you were just
visiting his father for Father's Day
well he's being a total [ __ ] about it
I can tell you that um I think you kind
of need to have the what-the-fuck
conversation right do you think if you
just like ignore me this is going to go
away oh hey you know what just seems to
my phone for if you're looking for
something you should find so well yeah
well I did and I did would you say that
to the cops and we found a kilo of
cocaine in the
your car well with the [ __ ] gold sort
of trunk of my car for you [ __ ]
looking for something you're going to
find it the cops going to be like oh ok
um he [ __ ] deserves to give you a
[ __ ] explanation a little better than
that and then you decide if you want to
work through it and if he doesn't want
to work through it [ __ ] dump his ass
this is this is the best you can do I
mean come on you're better than this
anybody's better than this
[ __ ] this guy alright [ __ ] does this guy
get off pulling a move like that there
were a response like that you know I
don't I don't get that and that's 100%
not fair to you [ __ ] this guy okay and
I'm not saying to leave the guy but if
he's not going to discuss it with you
the [ __ ] relationships over I the
trust is gone um alright good luck with
that and I'm sorry you're going through
that that's that's really unbelievably
painful and that's one of the worst
[ __ ] responses ever slash a little
legendary I'm not going to like teaching
guitar to a cute girl
I don't Jesus please tell me she's of
age I don't like the sound of this
already
alright hi Bill I've been listening to
your podcast for a while now it's
picturing this old guy playing Ben gays
and listens to this and now no and I now
know you Lynde you tend to give some
solid romantic relationship advice so I
was wondering if you and maybe the
lovely Nia - if she's around could help
me out with this one about two years
back I met this girl on my left in my
last year of university we had a lot of
the same classes together so we started
talking we have a lot of the same
interests she's really smart
she's funny and nice just all around my
type but it turns out she had a
boyfriend so I backed off pretty quickly
to this day we're friends and we try to
meet up every couple of weeks
is this when Harry Met Sally or is this
actually your life so about two months
ago she messaged me saying she always
wanted to learn how to play guitar and
that she finally bought what this she
wants she's in
you do I've been playing guitar for
years so I told I'd be happy to meet up
with her and show her some easy stuff to
get her started it's slowly morphed into
this thing where every week we meet up
after work for a couple hours
I teach I'll teach her chords and stuff
and we'll talk about life in general
anyway I noticed lately that a good
chunk of the conversation has been about
how she's been fighting with her
boyfriend the same guy as when we first
met yet how many more [ __ ] signals do
you need Jesus Christ is you not put
Christmas lights around her [ __ ]
vagina there she also keeps telling me
how amazing I'm being for teaching her
guitar and now I'm such a great guy plus
the last few week if ever a boyfriend
calls we're together she's been sending
it straight to voicemail
okay all right all right what does she
have to do grab you by the back of your
neck and [ __ ] push your face towards
there I mean come on I'm starting if the
sky goes I'm starting to get the feeling
she might be interested call me crazy
but this is where I need your advice I
tend to overthink things oh yeah I would
say because I tend to overthink things a
lot in general and it actually had
issues with the anxiety / depression in
the past I was wondering if you and Mia
could help me out here and I'm reading
am I reading too much into things or
does it seem like she's actually showing
some interest I'll take any help on what
I should do here Congrats on your lovely
daughter and getting the show picked up
for season 3 thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
um yes sir Jesus Christ your low
self-esteem jackass yeah she's into you
so what do you mean what you should you
do here just out looking tell her how
you feel I would just say listen I hope
I'm not out of line here I know you have
a boyfriend I know just as I said so
what's going on with your boyfriend you
don't seem happy you know your own
sending it the tenth pain you're always
fighting it sending it to the voicemail
you know you don't seem that very happy
and this is a 40
cent chance there she might cry when she
finally says no um and just say listen I
really like you and I don't I don't like
seeing you unhappy all right and not for
nothing
if you ever broke up with that guy I'd
love to take you out sometime
now would you like to learn how to do a
half-court that's it
how about that f as in [ __ ] me
yes that's what I would do I just asked
about a relationship and she's going to
say it's not going well and then just
say well you know just say what the [ __ ]
I just said and put it in your own words
all right what am i Cyrano de Bergerac
over here is that the right guy that the
guy telly you're the man
well are you bad remember that was that
that was that brownie Dangerfield movie
all right I got to go to the [ __ ]
Airport it's nine o'clock we'll get
picked up in 45 minutes and I haven't
even packed yet or have my [ __ ]
breakfast sandwich there um
that's it that's it yeah that is it go
[ __ ] yourselves
I will check in on you on Thursday and
I'm going to go home today I'm going to
watch the Formula One race that's what
the [ __ ] I'm but it's no I'm not landing
an invoice directly into the f is for
family [ __ ] I got to go back and start
writing again okay that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on I
already said it's on Thursday all right
bye